[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts potions professor
and later headmaster severus snape and
his most powerful spells and abilities
now one thing that i want to mention
right out of the gate is that snape is
one of the most powerful wizards in the
wizarding world and what was most
impressive about him is that he wasn't
even that old when he died
snape died at the tender age of 38 and
though he wasn't quite at the level of
voldemort or dumbledore he was getting
there and had he been around for a few
decades longer i think that snape may
have just had a shot at being the most
powerful wizard ever unfortunately we'll
never know and though i'm sure he had
the potential to achieve insurmountable
levels of power realistically he did
ultimately fall short of besting the
likes of voldemort and dumbledore
with all of that being said however
snape was still amazing and i feel like
sometimes he's little underrated
throughout the series time and time
again snape showcases spells and
abilities that are difficult to conjure
and often unique
he's also a well-rounded wizard because
he was never afraid of venturing to
experimentation with the dark guards he
knows the good spells and the more
sinister spells he knows it all the
snape is a testament to what can be
achieved if you're really dedicated to
something
as a student snape always had his head
in the books continually learning and
progressing he was focused and he didn't
let temporary satisfaction get in the
way of achieving more
learning more
though he had a segue down a dark path
the result of bullying and the loss of
his friendship with lily snape only used
his hatred for the marauders as fuel
it gave him the drive and the motivation
to be more
to do more
and today we're going to be diving in
and looking at snape's five most
powerful spells and abilities let's get
started
number five sektum sempra
coming in at number five on the list is
snape's very own spell sektum sempra
we first see sektum semper in the films
when harry uses it on malfoy in the
half-blood prince
sektim's emperor is a vicious dark curse
that acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts upon its target
often after being struck the target will
lay their motionless as they lose blood
it is somewhat of a specialty of snapes
and is featured in his textbook for
advanced potion making
the only treatment for sektum sempra is
vulnera sedan tor which was possibly
also invented by snape what's so
dangerous about sekum tempra is that it
was seemingly easy for harry to cast but
still nearly killed draco malfoy the
first time that he used it
while the unforgivable curses require
intent and an understanding of the
spells to effectively cast them
sektum sempra seemingly doesn't require
the same level of intent or deep
understanding
but still produces the same lethal
results i think that the only thing that
sets snape's spell apart from the
traditional unforgivable curses crucio
avada cadaver imperio
is that it has a counter charm
four creating potions
coming in at number four on the list is
snape's mastery of potion making the
snape held the position of potions
mastered hogwarts from 1981 to 1996
proving himself to be extremely adept at
the act of making potions snape having
always been studious and committed to
expanding his mind was very successful
at creating any sort of potion that he
desired
and thoroughly impressed his former
potions professor horace slughorn in his
schoolboy days
in fact he was so adept and in such a
league of his own
that snape basically rewrote a lot of
the instructions in his potions textbook
the same textbook that harry later
requires
when harry potter first attends
slughorn's class he hits the jackpot and
finds the former textbook of snape the
half-blood prince
at first this was just a regular
textbook to harry but as he began to
flip through it he noticed a few
peculiarities
the first thing being the inscription by
its former owner
this book is the property of the
half-blood prince
the next thing that he notices is that
on each page portions of the
instructions are scribbled out and
instead this half-blood prince character
had written in his own instructions
instructions that differed from what the
original recipe called for and what
harry quickly realized was that these
alternative instructions were far better
than the original instructions as he was
able to effortlessly produce the potions
that slughorn called for in each of his
lessons the book was like having cheat
codes to all of the potions lessons and
by following the instructions in the
book harry was able to thoroughly
impress lughorn this is a massive
testament to snape's prowess and potions
hogwarts had been around for over a
thousand years and the potions textbooks
were written by skilled potioneers but
snape had still managed to improve them
for the rest of the year harry continued
to follow the half-blood prince's
instructions wherever they deviated from
the original author libatius borage and
it resulted in slughorn raving about his
abilities there are many many potions in
harry potter and i wouldn't put it past
snape to create any one of them
powerful potions include veritas serum
which is essentially a truth potion
felix felicis or liquid luck which
grants unusually good luck and more
tension which gives the drinker a
powerful obsession or infatuation with
the giver of the potion and polly juice
potion which allows the drinker to
assume the appearance of someone else
snape could do them all
3. unsupported flight
coming in at number 3 is of course
unsupported flight or the ability to fly
the only other known witch or wizard
known to fly without a charm of some
sort is the dark lord himself voldemort
this achievement is extremely uncommon
and is the sign of a truly powerful
witch or wizard
jk rowling is reported to have stated
that all wizards have the power of
flight innately but that the vast vast
majority need a broom to achieve it in
the case of snape and voldemort they're
just so focused and powerful that
they're able to channel the power to fly
unsupported
harnessing the energy through themselves
rather than the broom
flying can come in handy in many
different circumstances
allowing you to get away quickly or
pursue a target with ease
unsupported flight should not be
confused with levitation which doesn't
work on humans and only allows objects
to fly a few feet above the ground
2. spell creation
coming in at number 2 is spell creation
spell creation can be highly dangerous
and has proven historically to be
extremely difficult
only witches and wizards with extreme
patience and an astounding understanding
of magic have been able to successfully
invent new spells snape who exhibits
both of these things has proven himself
to be quite successful at spell creation
having created a multitude of spells
over the years this list includes the
toenail growing hex which causes the
victim's toenails to grow alarmingly
fast langlock which affixes the victim's
tongue to the roof of their mouth the
mafiato charm which fills the ears of
anyone nearby with an unidentifiable
buzzing lever corpus which lifts the
victim's body into the air liberal
corpus which drops them out of the air
and lastly and perhaps most importantly
sektum sempra which i mentioned earlier
a few other witches wizards that were
introduced to have also created spells
but of all of them snape appears to have
the most impressive portfolio and i
think this is truly indicative of his
magical ability
i can't even begin to imagine what sorts
of spells snape would have come up with
had he lived a longer fuller life
number one occlumency occlumency is the
practice of magically closing one's mind
against legitimacy which involves
navigating through people's minds to
access their thoughts and feelings
sometimes even influencing them
zephyrus snape is a master oklahomans
and is perhaps one of the only people
besides dumbledore whose mind is safe
from a master legitimate like voldemort
snape acts as a double agent but is
still able to deceive lord voldemort
despite frequent interaction and i think
this truly speaks to his ability as an
oclumens perhaps even surpassing
dumbledore's abilities in the subject a
basic level oklahomans is simply able to
clear their mind in the event of a mind
infiltration while a master occlumens is
able to change their thought patterns in
order to further confuse the legitimates
given that occlumency is a rare skill
and that snape is so adept at it i
thought that it was fitting that it be
placed at the top of this list
and that concludes the list i really
wish snape had lived a longer fuller
life so that we could have seen the
boundaries of magic being pushed even
further
however in the time that he was around
he certainly contributed a lot
what do you guys think do you agree with
this list let me know down in the
comment section below
did snape invent vulneras and in tor or
grindelwald
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
[Music]
you